يصل الى فلوريدا للمثول امام المحكمه
الاردن يسقط مسيره محمله بالمخدرات قادمه
من سوريا
امريكي بعمر 14 عاما هو موظف في سبيس اكس
قريبا
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم الى تفاصيل
في محاكمه تاريخيه اخرى يعيد رئيس
الامريكيه السابق دونالد ترامب للمثول
امام القضاء في ميامي اليوم لمواجهه لائحه
اتهام تتعلق بقضيه الوثائق السريه وسوء
التعامل مع الاسرار الحكوميه يراقبون يرون
ان هذه المحاكمه تعد اخطر تحقيق جنائيا
يواجهه ترامب وقد يتسبب بعرقله محاولته
الفوز مجددا بمنصب سيد البيت الابيض فيما
يتوقع ان ينفي ترامب 37 تهمه وجهتها ضده
وزاره العدل يوم الجمعه الماضي وهي
اتهامات وصفها ترامب وانصاره بمحاوله
فاشله من الديمقراطيين لمنع ترشحهم مجددا
للرئاسه
نقله نوعيه ستحدثها امريكا في اطار دعمها
لاوكرانيا في مواجهه روسيا فمن المرتقبه
ان تقدم اداره رئيس جو بايدن قضاء
اليورينيوم المنظم بعد اسابيع من
المناقشات الداخليه حول هذا الموضوع
تقارير افادت ان هذه الذخيره الخارقه
للدروع قد اثارت مخاوف بشان الاثار الصحيه
والبيئيه على الرغم من ان بعض المسؤولين
يقولون انه لا يوجد عقبات حقيقيه امام
الموافقه على نقل هذه القذائف لكن اخرين
اعربوا عن قلقها من ان واشنطن يمكن ان
تتعرض لانتقادات بتقديم اسلحه تمثل خطرا
كبيرا على الصحه والبيئه
لا غذاء او دواء ولا وجود للحياه في
دارفور التي تتحول وتشهد فيها مدينه كتم
الى منطقه كوارث نتيجه استمرار والشداد
المعارك بين الجيش وقوه الدعم السريع في
مناطق عده السودان فوالي شمال دارفور نمر
عبد الرحمن قال في تعليقا على صفحته في
فيسبوك ان كنتم تعيش حالتك وارث انسانيه
وانها بحاجه لمساعدات عاجله ولا تزال تشهد
نزوح اعداد كبيره من الفارين الذين
يواجهون ظروفا انسانيه بالغه الصعوبه كما
دعا عبد الرحمن دعى المنظمات الانسانيه
الى التدخل العاجل لتقديم مساعدات انيه
للمتاثرين
الى الاردن هذه المره حيث اعلن الجيش ان
قوات حرس الحدود اسقط طائره مسيره محمله
بالمخدرات قادمه من سوريا حاولت اجتياز
الحدود الاردنيه ووفقا لبيان العسكريا
لمسؤول في القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
الاردنيه فان طائره كانت تحمل 500 غرام من
ماده الكريستال المخدره بينما جرى تحويل
المضبوطات الى الجهات المختصه واكيد ان
القوات المسلحه تماضيه في التعامل بكل قوه
وحزم مع اي تهديد على الواجهات الحدوديه
خصوصا تلك المتعلقه بتهريب المواد المخدره
وفي خبرنا الاخير اعلنت شركه سبيس اكس
المملوكه لايلون ماسك تعيين مهندس برمجيات
يبلغ من العمر 14 عاما ويدعى كايران كوازي
وذلك بعد ان اجتاز مقابله تقنيه صعبه لكنه
وصفها بالممتعه في المقابل افادت وسائل
اعلام بان كوازي اصبح اصغر شخص تم تعيينه
على الاطلاق بواسطه سبيس مشيره الى انه
درس علوم هندسه الكمبيوتر في السن الحاديه
عشر وسيتخرج من جامعه سانتا كلارا هذا
الشهر وبعد ان دخلها بمنحه واستثناء مخصص
للاطفال فائقي الذكاء